taste buds they coming to the mic
talking about the food they hate
talking about the food they like two
fools gonna fight but only one food can
be right
taste buds man yeah they're coming to
the mic i'm talking taste buds
hey taste buddies it's the taste buds
podcast i'm joe i'm sal
today we have changed our shirts no no
they know what we're doing sure these
people know what we're doing
i know but the thumbnail looks like it's
the same episode
you didn't bring a change of shirt no i
didn't bring a change well then we're up
ssc
we've been batch recording the entire
time you know i know but i like to
change either my shirt and socks you've
never
once with me changed your shirt no no is
that true
sal it is a hundred percent true all
right i have i just want
i just want people to easily recognize
when
one click you have never changed ever
please don't have a change that's what
people tell me i have a question for you
no
sometimes you'll because you're
sometimes you're a smart guy
you're smart guy the honesty is too much
and i have to close just too much we're
about to say you're you're
[Music]
you know that song yeah yeah that's a
that's classic i've been writing so long
who sings that it's kenny rogers
i don't know okay do you
what what what goes on sometimes with
your brain
[Music]
yeah well you're just ditto brother oh
he's that kid no you're a smart guy
you're one of the smartest guys i know
you're sharp you remember a lot of stuff
but sometimes you'll come out of left
field with a weird sometimes you'll come
out of left field with something where
i'm like i don't know where you got this
now i understand what you're saying
specifically do you know i have a lot of
stuff like that thing just said when you
go
i always change my shirt like you've
never
not only have you not we've discussed at
length how you haven't
okay which is why i think we should
maybe change shirts
i know we've talked about it and then we
had a discussion about why we didn't
need to
okay but i'm saying i thought the
outcome was that we should
no no remember last time i brought all
those shirts and then i didn't use them
oh that's on you no it wasn't it was
because we discussed it
really yeah i want you to know no
pressure network
when christy d brings his outfits we
change chrissy d is changing out started
brings changing outfits well like mariah
carey cribs
you know we have different ensembles
this is why you guys are getting the
hits
this is where you guys are getting the
views i just feel like you know when
they see like
me right and like in those little freeze
frame things we do
and it's the exact same thing they might
be like oh i think i might have seen
that one we have never changed once
we we dress like the like the slobs we
need to beef to do a show like this
this is what it is there's no pressure
people some people are like why don't
you sit in two chairs instead of a couch
why what are we talking about i own a
couch we're on the couch
cause i like his toes close to my knees
uh oh god these socks i would like you
to change your socks steelers
i know i understand it's the yellow toe
tips
that are bothering me right now i will
say your sock matches your cable knit
cardigan and i'm really here for it as
the kids say i know i know
i i match my shocks to my top your
shocks my socks to my top
they always match do you really always
yeah
you're supposed to do that when you wait
your socks are supposed to match your
shoes when you wake up every day
you pick out what first i pick out the
shirt i'm feeling and then you go
through the socks and say which socks
match this shirt yeah i go which which
shocks go
socks go beat that
which socks go with the outfit and what
if you don't have socks that match your
shirt
i mean pimp's always got to pull up a
contradictory piece do you match socks
to pants or shirt
watch sorry hold on a second
match your match your socks to the pants
you wear
not to the shoes now well that sounds
like a very i do agree with that
simple rule it's easier said than done
most men out there either have but i'll
tell you something
you're wearing a gray suit with a with a
pop and powder blue
shirt okay and you got some blue popping
socks on
against some brown shoes i mean it's
just
i mean you're all day baby sure but but
you get up your daily in your daily you
put on a shirt
and then after you you put on your shirt
you open the sock drawer and you go ah
what's going to go best with that yeah i
mean what do you what
i grab any sock you also wear
you know you know what i do i actually
more match my stretch
actually i match my sock to my sneaker
actually
i i match my socks i know if a sock's
not going to go
with the outfit but for the most part i
don't try to match
the shirt that's not i mean but i do
make sure the sock and sneaker
complement each other well at this point
you should be matching your socks to my
pants
uh today's topic today's debate
uh we say it's a debate it always ends
up being a screaming match
but uh it's bacon versus
it's a sausage one those are as big as
they come really
you know there's different episodes
sometimes there's brands sometimes it's
specific things sometimes it's more
broad
here you have a more broad staple foods
some might call them side dishes some
might call bacon and sausage meals
of their own or primarily the main
ingredient in a great meal
right we're not talking about them in a
breakfast capacity we said that right
we're talking about them in all their
glory with breakfast lunch dinner
everything okay
yeah we're spanning i wonder if people
play a little game before
at least before we say who's choosing
what
i can't believe yeah
talk to me once we expanded this
especially into in all their glory as
you put it yeah
that you are sticking with the one
you're sticking with
i'm in shock i'm in shock i'm curious to
see how you're going to do this
i don't think you have it in you i don't
think you're capable of it
i don't think you're good enough quite
frankly a minute to go in the bathroom
and vomit spaghetti on my shirt
carbonara bacon
pancetta is bacon basically right can we
say that no no no no no no because
italian bacon no no no no no cause
crepes weren't pancakes
we're not playing that game you know
what i i absolutely agree and i remove
remove remove remove i sometimes have
strokes pancetta from my uh
thank you thank you so sal is team bacon
and i am team sausage yeah well you know
what
you can begin because you let me begin
the last one
what is there to say wrong
the versatility which is an argument you
love to go to on this podcast
the versatility of sausage
let's just start with breakfast you go
link
you go patty let's move on to lunch
a sausage and pepper sandwich a sausage
and an onion sandwich
a sausage pepper is an egg sandwich then
we move into dinner
you can put sausage and uh to the tomato
gravy with pasta you could put it into
your lasagna
you can uh you know and now we're
starting to get into anduli sausage and
chicken
pineapple whatever the hell you have it
sausage there's all kinds of flavors all
kinds of varieties now i'm going to
sweet italian sausage man myself
that's mainly what i roll with but i
mean you go into the sausage aisle at
the at the supermarket and if you want
to get technical we could say hot dogs
but i know we won't because we couldn't
say pancho why don't you even say that
though
that's like and that's like in a
courtroom drama when they say something
they're not supposed to and they go
overruled but they got it in there i
know because
yeah i'm beating a little [ __ ] but what
we can say what we can absolutely say is
bratwurst
kielbasa i mean the sausage train
is car after car after car
there is so much to explore on this
express ride
and bacon yeah with your eggs
you put it in a blt you throw it on top
of a burger
and we're done here we're done
we're done here where do you go after
that
i'm curious okay okay um
i don't disagree with the
versatility of a sausage however
in all those dishes you named
when i bite into a sausage
it never blows me away it it always is
just sausage i don't know what it is but
it's not anything i'm crazy excited over
ever
and a lot of times i actually don't like
it
i gotta be in the mood for sausage
because it just feels even more so to me
than bacon
like just a weird mishmash mishmash
heart attack did i not hit the
i didn't oh [ __ ] it's out that's why we
got
pimpsicle we're all over the place we're
all over it's out okay
i just sausage you know you know what
you know what this is this is the image
i can't get out of my head with a
sausage
people putting all that all those
animal carvings and endings the hoof the
foot
does this you brought up frankfurters
like it's just
all this [ __ ] that's being churned and
put into these
sausage casings it just feels
like the most disgusting batch
amalgamation of loose end meats coming
together
mushed together but that's not what
sausage is that's not what good sausages
that's not what quality sausages
quality sausage is ground up pork meat
that is seasoned and then put into the
casing but all the different
things you just named are not that any
quality version of any one of them is
look fact the best hot dogs sausage
concealer hot dogs are at the table but
the best hot dogs are beef hot dogs so i
mean you know okay
so a sausage consists of meat cut into
pieces
or ground mixed with other ingredients
and filled into a casing
it's almost like exactly what i just
said that's weird i thought it was
exactly what i just
no you said the hooves where do you want
meat it's just cuts of meat
no no no no don't hold on ingredients
don't incorporate hooves into just
cuts of meat that's not fair what i'm
saying like when i think of a sausage
it's like throw it it's the kitchen sink
it's not the kitchen sink that's what
cheap sausages
include a cheap starch filler such as
bread crumbs or greens
seasoning and flavoring such as spices
spices and sometimes
others such as apple and i can't rick
flares in the way i can't okay
it's apple and leek so so right now
we're seeing
seasoning grains apples and leeks as the
lower ingredients i'm not seeing hooves
still
i still haven't seen hooks all right
hold on what part of the pig is used to
make the sausage
the shoulder the butt no the shoulder
butt not the butt
and the loin yeah
pork butt is pork shoulder all right
well let's talk about this when no
because you're wrong well when bacon is
involved right right if you go
bacon or sausage for any breakfast food
whether it's a bacon egg and cheese
a side with my eggs or my toast and the
world knows this
bacon winslet so now every time she just
swipe sausage off to breakfast
stop it you're nuts right i go when i go
to mcdonald's breakfast
the greatest breakfast anybody can ever
have to pull up if a bacon egg and
cheese
sells more or bacon sausage and cheese
at mcdonald's please you want to go at
it
oh you want that thing i think bacon and
cheese is out selling the sausage with
eggs i know it is they named it the
mcmuffin after their key
after their their their centerpiece
sandwich the egg mcmuffin
there is not a bacon mcmuffin there is a
sometimes bacon egg and cheese is always
chosen over sausages sausage egg and
cheese mcgriddles
top not no power ranking mcdonald's best
breakfast sandwich
but this is oh wait this is number 12
opinion no no no no i'm talking about
sales no no this is number 12.
go down the number one pimp and scroll
backwards let's see what we got from
number one backwards
but this is this is a writer's opinion i
want sales let's go
okay let's go somewhere else all right
you know you know what we when you get
real on your high horse like that real
quick
and you start hooting and you start
hollering yeah okay just take it down a
notch because
you're basing it on something that's
just another guy's opinion or gal
i mean i mean do you ever get the jimmy
dean's bacon sandwiches no you get the
you get the sausages
extra crispy bacon burnt bacon cider
bacon everything bacon
bacon bacon bacon did they sell t-shirts
and merch
i love bacon can i pay you in bacon
bacon is like
coffee that's how people feel about
bacon if you love bacon
you'll love can i tell you something
okay and bacon
whoops sausage's ass that's right as far
as breakfast foods go
so if we're cutting it up into three
three sections on a pie chart of
breakfast lunch and dinner
bacon is taking the breakfast third over
sausage that's number one
that's funny because the highest selling
breakfast
uh restaurant uh mcdonald's uh
when you get the big breakfast platter
bacon ain't nowhere to be found on that
thing you get a sausage patty with it
and it is
impeccable what do you mean you get
bacon with that
please nobody's ever gotten bacon with
that joe
these sentences that you say people have
gotten bacon see if it's an option i
mean you can't just say a sentence you
set yourself up to be
to be immediately i have no one ever
ever ordered
bacon right there on the menu it's not
on the menu
the bacon is in the sandwiches the bacon
at mcdonald's is not on the menu as a
side dish
like the sausage it doesn't come when
you can get like
that foam with the pancakes in it and
the side of it it's sausage every time
it's sizzling
eggs and pancakes that's what it is
that's what it is pimp look it up look
up mcdonald's big breakfast
hold on let's see let's see what he's
got for us here real real quick the
statistics show how much bacon is
consumed each year according to the
statistic
16.4 million americans used i can't
read that five pounds or more of bacon
in 2020.
okay okay so i mean that's not a good
statistic saying people are eating more
bacon
than they did last year 1.1 billion
pounds of sausage
sales are up i don't know what this does
for us it does nothing well what about
does mcdonald's sell more bacon or
sausage
google's not going to know that but i
could tell you this google knows
stuff you can go right to their
breakfast menu and you ain't gonna see
bacon on there as a side dish
things you didn't know about mcdonald's
breakfast you're not gonna what item
does mcdonald's sell the most of
you're not gonna see it no it's not on
now
ten ten top selling uh uh
uh mcdonald's menu items of all time
here we go mcgriddle's breakfast
sandwich number
ten that had bacon on it oh what did i
just see
i think i saw a sausage mcmuffin with
egg
right behind the egg that's that's
canadian bacon buddy
that's the egg mcmuffin keep scroll up a
little bit you'll see it
[ __ ] i thought i saw it scroll down
but that's mcgriddles in general that's
not mcgriddles with bacon specifically
it's saying mcgriddle's period
i mean i don't know why we're tying this
to mcdonald's breakfast
because mcdonald's breakfast is amazing
and the fact that
sausage is their cornerstone why don't
you tell the fine folks out there what
you had twice this week
why don't you tell them what you ordered
twice this week
did you get it twice this year did you
order wendy's twice i ate wendy's today
on my way here today he ate wendy's now
if you watch this show
you know he did wendy's versus
mcdonald's and he came down hard on
wendy's
and today he walked into my home with a
wendy's yeah
and you know why i did that you know
what i did that i'm glad you brought it
up this way i told you about it
because i had to record four episodes of
a podcast with you and i said i can't
feel deliciously sluggish right now
i need to get something that tastes like
real food
quickly and i got wendy's so i got a
lettuce wrapped grilled chicken sandwich
so funny that it's the real food
anyway all right look look here's no no
here's my point
tell me tell me to tell me okay sausage
gravy at breakfast
oh my god i just remembered sausage
gravy and
biscuits that's not sausage what are you
talking about you can't argue sausage
it's crazy
you can't argue sausage gravy you say
that's like before
when you wanted to recall i seem to
recall being somewhere
where they were not arguing gravy i seem
to recall really quick though hold on a
second i just seem to recall being
somewhere
where um i was told by you once in the
show
that i was somewhere where they served
peach pie that i should remember
i had peach pie at an event right that i
was in attendance of and i seem to
remember
at that same event during the breakfast
a sausage home style gravy being served
sure with biscuits
and no bacon no bacon on the menu hold
on a second
you can't argue for it's for gravy we're
talking sausage versus bacon
you said sausage is off the table with
breakfast
yeah but yes no no i'm saying it's off
the table i said
as far as the two meats go in a
breakfast capacity bacon
if i wrote if the tweet was better
breakfast food bacon or sausage
you would go down like a house of cards
it's bacon everyone
my point is bacon is branded as people's
like i
die on the hill of bacon you could
google it right now bacon merch
it's coming up strips of bacon like you
know
like you know i love you more than bacon
is a saying
you had me at bacon okay everything
bacon because
bacon you had me at bacon uh i love you
more than basically
look up sausage shirts now yeah sausages
congrats congrats
you're supporting a food where you can
buy t-shirts of it at hot topic
uh let's see what we got for you guys
already here's what the fur
here's a sausage shirt that comes up
what it says on it ready the shirt says
this is what the sausage merch says
sausage
that's dessert it says where's the
slogans that go with it babe
sausage there's nothing like it well
this is coming from the guy that bragged
about how combos doesn't need to plaster
their logo all over everything neither
the sausage sausage doesn't have its
hooks in people the way that bacon does
it's not about hooks it's about it's
better
it's about a better food okay so you
still haven't answered my question
top of a burger club sandwich
with your eggs okay
about sizzling crispy bacon then a
couple of those greasy links that roll
tortillas
you want to talk about something to not
be excited about it at breakfast
you get baked bacon often is
is floppy it's fatty
it's greasy uh but but still you haven't
answered my question
okay now all of a sudden club sandwiches
yeah great bacon right on top the blt
love it the blts the variation of the
blt
i love the beer the number one thing
that cannot happen without that sandwich
is the bee
that's funny because i see a lot of
people ordering it without sandwiches
where are your sausage sandwiches
the sausage and pepper sandwich that is
besides that at a stand beside
every street fair besides a sausage parm
sandwich
besides that besides that what's besides
the blt the bacon has no other sandwich
sandwiches it's an addition to the club
sandwich i could talk to you all
about a sausage burrito a sausage
burrito
let's talk chorizo tacos chorizo
burritos
you could sausage goes into all kinds of
people put bacon in their pasta
and carbonara sauce you think they're
not doing that with sausage
i only have breakfast and a blt i throw
it in a pasta dish like nobody's
business
what do you nothing excuse me how often
are you doing that
right when you take into account that
908 million pounds of bacon
were sold in 2015 you might think that
team bacon comes out on top
however a 2016 harris poll conducted for
the
national hot dog and sausage council
they're including hot dogs
found that a majority of americans 89 of
their respondents
favor sausage overall they included hot
dogs no they don't they're just the hot
dog and sausage council
one point okay according to figures for
2019 dinner sausage sales
were nearly 1.1 billion pounds
a 1.4 increase over 2017
with dollars spent exceeding 3.9 billion
dollars
breakfast sausage sales comprise more
than
316 million pounds
and 1.23 billion in sales
8 from 2018. okay look 0.8
okay look i still feel
that defeated no in my heart even coming
into this i thought
i think bacon's a front runner over
sausage do you think it is
i think it is but you know look you know
we we we we come to this place a lot on
this show
just because it's a front runner no no
no no no no no that's what i'm saying
i'm just saying like
yeah of course everybody's gonna pick
bacon it's like saying you know
it's it's it's oh breakfast food i
really do think they'd pick it if we
said breakfast food
but you know you have a lot of variety
going on with sausage
you do i mean it's a world out there a
universe to explore there's a world of
sausage out there
it's a world it comes in all different
forms
it's it's there's groundswell i'll give
it to you when you have it you could put
sausage into
sloppy joes it it it kicks it up 10
levels it's amazing
who's doing that i combine sausage with
beef with my sloppy joe recipe and it's
insane
and a lot of people could probably throw
bacon in it too then
you could never seen anybody do it this
bacon chapstick this bacon flavored
bacon chapstick let me tell you guys
baking soda but sausage doesn't cross
over into dessert mother f
there's bacon bacon baby chocolate i'm
gonna say something
spicy too they put that um the pep the
the spicy it's spicy speaking i swear to
you it's delicious
i'm gonna say something imagine dipping
i have never seen this chocolate sauce
i'm gonna say something i've never said
on the show and i'm saying it to you the
audience salty and sweet if you
eat dessert bacon or have bacon chips
you're a disgusting wrong it's artistic
you're disgusting
you're not no you're not it's disgusting
that's disgusting
chocolate covered bacon is delicious
it's disgusting and it's like when
people have
maple bacon and it's caked in the syrup
and everything it's gross dude
it's gross bacon bits are sold as a
bacon bits on a salad oh on a salad i
like bacon bits on a salad
hold on you went off on the cob salad as
the one of the best salads ever made
love it
what's one of the main ingredients of a
cobb salad bacon okay
so now we got bacon egg and cheese you
know we got candy
we got bacon and a blt we got bacon in
the club sandwich we got bacon and pops
but you know we got
chocolate bacon we got bacon and salads
and you're telling
beers that sausage is a whole world of
it but there's not a whole world
here's what holds true about every one
of those dishes that you just said
okay with the exception of maybe maybe
breakfast and
even that's a stretch bacon is never
the star of the show you don't get a
bacon
entree ever you don't get a just
straight up bacon sandwich
bacon basically doesn't bacon take over
whatever it's in like bacon is always
the star of the show
it's pushy i'll give you that bacon is
always the star of the show you throw
bacon but you
you know what i'm saying you can't go
blt it's not tl you don't go to an
italian restaurant and go give me the
bacon and onions
for dinner tonight you don't do that so
i got a question for you what company
was founded by caltech scientists and
former smokers
and they created a better and cleaner
nicotine alternative
that they developed for three years and
it was made for people not patients do
you have any do you have any clue
i have one guest and one guest only i'm
going with lucy babe
lucy lucy is that brand the convenient
and discreet
lozenges and gum that you can suck on
and chew
anywhere gonna help you get off those
smokes
i have uh smoked at times in my life
products like this can help greatly but
i never had great luck with nicotine
gum or the standard things you buy at
the store maybe even chewing
you know a matchstick like an old
drifter
yeah i never had much luck with that
licking an ashtray just to get you a
little fix
yeah because you're a tobacco junkie
here
is a new product a real product that's
going to help you cut back or get off
those smokes all together it's 20 21.
get rid of your cigarettes unplug your
vape throw out your dip get some lucy
nicotine gum or lost
this stuff is made for people by people
not
patients you understand listen to me i'm
in the gym i'm on a plane you light up a
cigarette you're
never problem in the gym i can never
people might get violent
if i was if i join a gym if i finally
decide at the
decades to join a gym it's for a health
reason if i go in there
and you're a smoker and you like a
cigarette you are ostracized from the
community
supposed taste fine fair enough but you
know what you can do you could be on the
treadmill you could pop in
a cherry lozenge a pomegranate stick of
chewing gum
and you get your fix but it's healthier
for you it's healthier for everyone else
a subscription to lucy also comes
directly to your door each month it's so
simple
you don't have to leave the house which
i love right think about that
you're not talking about an active group
of people the smokers
yeah think about when you need it and
you don't have it you're like yo i need
a cigarette man
this is coming right to your house now
you got it in your pocket
and i guarantee you it's cheaper than
cigarettes because tastebud listeners
you go to lucy.co.comco and use the
promo code tastebuds and you're going to
get 20
off the entire product line the gum or
the lozenges
it's lucy dot co dot co use the promo
code
taste buds at checkout also i got to
give a disclaimer this product does
contain nicotine it's derived from
tobacco nicotine is an addictive
chemical
but this is still much much much
healthier why do you always got to give
that disclaimer and like rain we were
having a party and you got to bring
bring it down with the disclaimer you
know because i'm not having somebody
come after me
uh but you understand every they don't
know this but beyond lucy whenever we're
hanging out and everyone's having a good
time he has a disclaimer
you know it just so happens that it's
just this happens to us all the time
with the disclaimer
joey disclaimers go get these losses
taste buds okay
our listeners twenty percent off
lucy.com promo conte
promo tastebuds lucy dot co
and be sure to use that promo code taste
buds sally babe
hey this is it oh we got
this is how how nice this is joey roses
aka joe derose's sandwich shop has
brought a platter of sandwiches
yes a platter of sandwiches for us to
eat and taste it now
because of the nature of quarantine i
have not been down to the shop this is
gonna be my first
bite this is it this is your first one
and i've plugged the sandwich pop up
many times we're at the stand in nyc in
union square
uh every week always follow the
instagram at joeyroseshard8.
i'm glad that dorykkova too you bit it
and then put it right down on top of
a plate of clean sandwiches
jesus christ we're at the stand in union
square every week where does bread from
we make it what we make it we make it in
hotel
we make it in-house quality stuff eight
sandwiches for eight bucks a piece you
can't beat it
these are cheaper than going to subway
and it's ten times the quality
so i mean come on down enjoy us
i'm not kidding around this is dull
absolutely delicious like
home run quality ingredients they fill
you better
they taste better they are better joey
roses we do
quality better that's right sandwiches
elevated
a brand based around phallus talk
put it in your mouth you can get a
sausage sausage can be the main
they might not be apples to apples it
could be the same
the main protein of the meal you know
that anduli sausage can be the main
protein of the meal
bratwurst can be the main protein in the
meal you can throw sausage on the grill
we're not talking about even canadian
bacon we're not talking about the thick
cut
stop bacon don't you dare breathe okay
right now i went to quality eats
not even like a month ago and i had a
meal that was this thick
thick cut bacon with a jalapeno jelly
i've had that equipment peanut butter
i've had that it's delicious it's
unbelievable it's an appetizer
it's you ever go to uh peter lucas or
any steakhouse and get a really thick
cut of bacon and you can get like it's
the main protein give you
one no they give you one babe they give
you one
they give you one piece of bacon as an
appetizer it is not on the menu is
amazing it's a world of bacon i'm
telling you you get
there's not a there's not amazing you
know what you can't do with bacon
you know you can't do a bacon at a
cookout he can flame a toothpaste i
swear to god disgusting pull it up
that's disgusting i'm not saying it i'm
just saying it's it's more popular than
sausage
look at this boom look at bacon-flavored
gum
this big this sucks with just pictures
of bacon pajamas we're just pictures of
bacon
listen to me listen to me you know what
you can't do it at a club i can't throw
it hold on please hold on
strips of bacon whatever you know what
you can't do i've seen sausage and eggs
who are these animals brushing their
teeth with bacon
and making their cars
because you told me there's a whole
world of sausages listen to me listen to
me
here's what you can take in south you
gotta let me say this a beer
you gotta let me say this i've been
trying to say this for five minutes
bacon candy canes
you got to let me say it please go let
me say it let me say this to you
you don't got to put the mic down just
control yourself
you know what you can't do at a cookout
you can't throw bacon on the grill and
then put it on a roll you can do that
with sausage
you go to a cookout you throw sausage on
the grill you win
that goes a huge long way in making the
argument that it's its own
thing look at look at how big bacon is
like
in the world of entertainment bacon is
like illustrated
it's in toothpaste soda beer
of entertainment what are you what are
you talking about bacon is a star
you know bacon you you want to talk
about bacon star power
you're telling me that sausage is more
versatile and it can be used in more
dishes
and i'm telling you if that's even true
by the way i just debunked that because
i named
places that bacon go that sausage
doesn't even go
okay there's no sausage soda there's no
sausage toothpaste
sausage for shits and giggles do google
sausage soda
sausage soda oh look at that sausage
toothpaste also disgusting
sausage soda it doesn't come up though
yeah because it's got clash of dignity
now so what i'm saying is how good
how much of a response will p do people
have right to their love of bacon that
bacon now
is just like a way to brand items it's
psychotic it's it's
it's on stickers it's scratching sniff
stickers
but that's something people bacon
wouldn't have achieved that if people
didn't have a
attack staunch loyalty it's heck
it's hacked it's not hack it's heck you
know what bacon is
you know what bacon is i'll tell you
what bacon look at those look at those
you know what bacon those vans it's
bacon vans
you know what bacon is i'll tell you
what bacon is ready for this man's shoes
bacon is this is what bacon is bacon is
when you go into target
and they have like the retro looking
stranger things
t-shirt you go oh christ this is so
hacky does it matter
somebody actually bought this and they
made a cool t-shirt and sausages you get
real
sausages let me finish my point
sausages you go down to the east village
to a vintage store
and they've got a freddie mercury solo
album shirt hanging up for 250 dollars
you're like that is a
i gotta that's i'm buying no i don't i
say
are these people trying to do they think
i fell off a turnip truck and i was born
this afternoon
they're going to charge 250 dollars for
someone's shirt that they've done in the
garbage
no it's not no it's not yes it is no
it's not yes it is
yes it is look there's animated sausages
hot dogs
well i mean you keep bringing up sausage
or hot dogs when you don't want them to
be part of the argument you're going to
keep bringing them up i'll
talk about it if people didn't love
bacon this way
it would have never been oh wait what it
became bacon is like
okay ready here's the other grapes
please hold on here
good no go ahead go ahead all right
sorry go ahead you know how people
die for chocolate they die for coffee
i feel like bacon has achieved that
status where people are like
give me my bacon i love bacon i love you
more than bacon don't talk to me unless
i have bake
always with the bacon who is i feel
bacon it's like that's how much people
love it and that's why bacon now
has a life of its own as just this why
are you talking
as if constructing a baconator
construction foreman
or walking up to stands on the street
how about the burger right the baconator
ain't nothing without the burgers
burger is one of the all-time greatest
foods ever invented might be the
best-selling food item other than pizza
on the planet and a bacon burger
is at the top the pinnacle of that
that whole group bacon takes something
that is that popular
and brings it to a whole other level you
are you are making a case that because
bacon can't just be
the main ingredient that it is not as
good
i disagree i think there's a versatility
bacon i think it's far-reaching
i think it improves every dish and when
it's in the dish it becomes the dominant
there's
people love bacon cheeseburgers they get
bacon cheeseburgers because they need to
have i love bacon cheeseburgers
it's not because i need to have bacon i
don't
put sausage on a cheeseburger of course
not i'm not a lunatic
okay that's crazy that's like saying
strawberry ice cream
want to put it on a cheese with bacon on
a cheeseburger i love bacon on a
cheeseburger and you know what it knows
its place
under the cheese behind the burger it is
not the star of the show
that's my point i put a lot of things on
a cheeseburger i put ketchup on a
cheeseburger
i wouldn't pit ketchup against sausage
and go oh
but a ketchup makes a cheeseburger so
much better well of course it does
it's not as good as sausage on its own
on its own goes a long way with me and
here's what's going to
here's what i was going to say earlier
sausage can be made out of multiple
meats
bacon can't you could smoke it different
ways you have turkey bacon
you ever have turkey bacon you know what
it tastes like turkey that's what it
tastes like wait a minute
chicken sausage tastes like sausage
juice i know i know that you didn't just
say two sentences in a row
bacon can't be made out of different
meat have you ever had turkey bacon yeah
i'm saying it sucks but it can be made
i know i wasn't
i was saying it in a funny way it can be
made out of it's
unsuccessful when they do it is what
i've tried to become popular according
to
google 1990s oh yeah there you go the
movement has been traced to the late 90s
when high protein foods became a more
prominent diet focus
due in part to the atkins diet since
then bacon-focused events and gatherings
celebrating the food
have been reported and bacon-related
experts have been featured in media
accounts
congrats that your food your food got
popular with the worst era of snl in the
backstreet boys
[Music]
the fall of western civilization
coincides with your popularity 90s were
great snl what are you talking about
i no late 90s i don't remember i mean
it's a joke you're going to nail me to a
post over here i mean we're having a
debate
i'm making a joke i'm going to take what
you do i'm going to use it again that's
why
we got this wait did you hear how hard
pimp laughed when i said it i do it for
the kids like this
i don't do it for you all right here's
my point
[ __ ]
give me that whiskey
i do feel like i'm gonna have a heart
attack when i eat either
i have lost can i be honest with you i
at least lost
at least oh oh you son of a [ __ ]
i have lost my taste for plain bacon
i can't eat it in the morning anymore it
tastes like i'm licking salt
okay i enjoy salt yes i enjoy it on a
burger
even when i get a blt these days i get
it i used to get it with extra bacon i
don't do that anymore i
add avocado to break up the saltiness of
it
i can't i used to get it on pizza i
don't do it anymore it's too
overpowering
now bacon does add interesting flavor to
things i'm not arguing that
i agree that it does but most of the
time
it's the loud guy at the party it's
pushing its way in and everybody's got
to pay attention to just that
and i don't think that's a good thing uh
i don't really believe what you just
said why don't you tell me you don't
believe me i think that you you know you
it's
it's smoking mirrors i mean like he's
bacon's not the loud guy at a party
you know it's just not try eating
anything almost
anything that has taken it all you can
taste this you ever see
um espionage what the hell is that
entourage
yeah no you know you know when uh when
what's his face he's
bacon's ari that's exactly my point no
he's a loud guy on the phone yesterday
number one
when he's like i am queen's boulevard
remember that famous line
bacon is breakfast bacon is breakfast
some people tell me like i can't have
it's his breakfast is orange juice man
i'll tell you what's shot
breakfast dude no one's like sausage is
breakfast
are you cr that was why i brought up the
picture saying that
burger king food but bacon has taken the
burger king came
out with the chris sandwich one of the
great breakfast sandwiches that has ever
been created
when bacon when burger king came out
with the sandwich they had two options
yeah ham sausage bacon wasn't even an
option initially bacon was not an option
at mcdonald's breakfast
initially the stars of wendy's new
breakfast lineup
is sausage and chicken bacon is playing
in the background to that
i love your haphazard stats you're
throwing around me
about food i eat a lot of fast food
breakfast food
breakfast but i'm telling you i'm i'm
talking about bacon versus sausage
not whether bacon was available on the
crew sandwich
i understand i'm saying there's a reason
why that is not an out of the gate
because people like
sausage now this is a candied bacon
that's another one not chocolate covered
bacon candy
disgusting but it is not you would be
right except for that
you are wrong it's gross i thought
myself that sounds delicious and as soon
as i bit it i said we're flying too
close to the sun here
this is disgusting
all right let's just do it
that's i mean look that was a good
debate i now i i will say this
humbly i think that bacon will take it
and i will say humbly that that was a
tough argument for me
all right i will say that okay i don't
necessarily think bacon is winning
eleven thousand 600 votes
that's a hot one today um i can't even
explain it or justify it
but sausage is just better nothing is
nastier than biting a hard mystery
nugget in a piece of sausage
what about that that's what i would say
that's tough that's hoof
every once in a while when you get that
rubbery thing that's possible it's a
little good village
bristle oh yeah let's talk about that
let's talk about gristle let's talk
about what happens
before you throw this up let's talk
about gristle i'm so glad because i i
would have not been able to sleep but
that's not frequently
we closed this up and then later i would
have like but that sounds frequent
that's not frequent that's like me
saying when you get a piece of bacon and
it's all
fat that tastes like pencil eraser on
the side that's not a fair
that's unfair but the thing is that when
i'm chewing the fat on a bacon
i know it's fat when there's gristle
it's united
no it's gristle i'm telling you it's
identified we just identified crystals
like hoof
and ligaments no it's not gristle comes
from gristles
what's the hard stuff
what is the hard stuff in sausage oh
what we thought a tiny
chip of boom you're going to make an
omelet you got to break some eggs
sometimes it's a chip
sometimes it's connective tissue or a
ligament
or a tendon okay fat is fat
we need fat in everything i eat fat in a
in a finest steak
a marbled steak gives more flavor fat we
are used to
but bone ligament tendon gristle
hoof you're gonna make it you gotta
break some eggs
yeah you know what it's a more
sophisticated food
sorry it's not as easy as slicing a
piece of the stomach or whatever the
hell the sausage is made out of and
throwing it into a pan
it's not as easy okay it's not as easy
to do
all right what else we got bacon i mean
look at how all this that guy's gonna be
the winner obviously okay that's
amazing uh i don't eat meat okay
this is graphic but ever since i was a
kid i was scared to eat bacon because
there was a serial killer
who chopped off his victims and fed them
to his pigs then sold the bacon so long
story short i vote for sausage
uh bacon bacon takes it for me but it
definitely had to be crispy
if you pick sausage take a look at
yourself in the mirror and ask yourself
this
why do i hate freedom all right that's a
contender for best one
uh bacon bacon even goes in ice cream i
was pleasantly surprised
by it being good um wait wait
who can say no to sausage freedom to the
point
a sausage sandwich at a fair or festival
is great but mako
bacon maple bacon donut is in a class by
itself
these animals who is eating that at the
donation store
i forgot all about it
you got bacon you got bacon as a snack
it's breakfast lunch dinner snack
sweet salty you got it all over the
place man all over the place
it seems to me that bacon is far
preferred by americans but as a brit
i think that may be because you haven't
tasted the best sausages
british bangers i should have brought
that up bangers and mash damn it
don't get me wrong i like bacon a lot
but a proper sausage is
chef's kiss thank you owen gibbs
no one says bring home the sausage yes
hold on bring home the bacon originated
in the 1100s
ain't no way society has had it wrong
for almost a solid thousand years
bacon for the week ages he just did the
thing you yell at me for doing
no one says you don't know that you
don't no no but
what the saying is bro let's go to the
let's see who won we've read enough
comments let's see who won
yeah i want to i want to see who won the
poll let's see who won the poll
jesus oh baby oh god guys
guys oh my god the 8.4
[Music]
that's more than double it's a trouncing
if they wrote it up in the papers it
would be called the trouncing
oh my god i thought i was going to lose
but not by that much i didn't either i
didn't either i thought it would be
closer than that
give it to this guy that's too funny
that's not him though that's just i know
but it's just so funny dude
at cherish underscore well actually this
might be a woman that pro
cherish at cherish underscore x 0x0
uh follow follow cherish
uh thank you bacon i mean look at how
that looks when you eat a sausage that's
really funny
yeah oh it's a guy putting a whole
sausage in his mouth in one shot
and i can't tell if it's a camera trick
or if he's really eating the whole thing
i think it's a camera trick but no he's
eating that what are you nuts he's one
throat
he like goes he like swallows it whole
or something
that's wild that is wild i mean look at
the way she's looking at him the girl
the woman that's real
right now she looks he looks very
familiar too doesn't he yeah he does
look
familiar i don't know uh in any case
listen to me i still love you i love you
too
this that that one guy i mean i got
spanked on that one that hurt
yeah all right folks joe derosa comedy
on instagram and twitter follow if you
like
uh joey rose's sandwich shop uh at the
stand in union square
and we'll see you in hell podcast pat
walsh myself debate horror movies
at patreon.com wsyihpodcast
for new episodes and back catalog
available wherever you get your shows
that's it um volcano on social media
uh and what else check out the no press
network on youtube
hey one big thing i want to say is if
you guys are liking this the best way
that you can help us
is to subscribe to our youtube channel
called no presh uh and to wherever you
listen to the podcast too
itunes spotify apple if you can just uh
rate us and maybe leave a comment i
think that really really helps guys that
really
does help click the like buttons if
you're into the videos please
uh hit the uh hit the bell icon so
you're reminded whenever we launch a new
video
uh i'm on an app called community uh and
uh i
it gives me a phone number when i open
the app i can see text and text you guys
and
and i i put up a lot of like exclusive
stuff there and stuff first before i
post to social media
the number is 718-260-6619 it doesn't
mean i'm going to see you
and i can't respond to everybody but i
do try to respond to dozens of people a
day
taste buds they coming to the mic
talking about the food they hate
talking about the food they like two
fools gonna fight but only one food can
be right
taste buds man yeah they're coming to
the mic i'm talking taste buds
if you don't want your purse they'll
take your pay stubs